bombes de peinture multicolores pochoir
fait maison sur le parking d'un
supermarché du centre-ville
les jeunes via zone et créer un nouvel
univers lundi du coup on a commencé à
faire les pochoirs et puis hier va
commencer à prendre sur les verts est-ce
que vous représentez sur ses murs
plusieurs logos histoire de décor et qui
parle pas le djembé le saxophone la
guitare la note de musique
les étoiles que des instruments de
musique pourquoi parce qu'en fait quand
on a réfléchi au départ on a on a décidé
d idées sur chaque mur ce qui fait que
nous on est le thème de la musique sur
ce mur là la musique le sport mais aussi
les animaux ou l'espace d'ici la semaine
prochaine
cinquante mètres linéaires de murs
blancs témoigneront du talent de ces
artistes en herbe
là on a des jeunes dont la plupart
partent en vacances ou alors qu'ils
partiront une semaine ou deux peut-être
et ça leur permet un peu de passer des
vacances à vierzon mais en bougeant un
petit peu court le directeur du magasin
avait mis cette toile géante à
disposition des adolescents et leur
avait laissé carte blanche
il découvre les premières heures je
m'attendais pas à autant de dessins
différents de formes différentes
ça amène des couleurs ça même une gaieté
ça amène la jeunesse parce que c'est ça
aussi ça a fait participer un peu tout
le mandat
et puis ça montre que bay au centre
ville on a quelque chose de nouveau qui
peut être chouette et qui peut être très
bien et qui est fait par les jeunes de
la ville de vierzon et cette fresque
servira de décor un festival de cultures
urbaines organisé en septembre